hey everyone it's Mike here and welcome
back to my channel I'm glad you can join
me for today's uh second video you know
I'm gonna be talking about prominent
points of control because there's a
question that came in uh from uh Nissan
adaf hope I got your name right
um he's saying um hi Mike your videos
are really helpful I like the video
about Prominent Point of control and how
to use it with Divergence to create a
system however go charting platform uh
does lose the signals while scrolling
and I noticed I missed a few trades
because of that hope you can make a
video uh on the same and you know go
charting is a for those of you that
aren't uh necessarily familiar with go
charting yet it is a web-based platform
that has recently added my indicators
I've worked with the programmers
directly to make sure everything works
properly as opposed to you know I see a
lot of people out there copying my
indicators and you know sometimes they
really miss the mark on some but and I
don't say anything I just let the people
out there use it you know it does give
sort of a bad name to it but you know
you know people misunderstand the order
flow but anyway you know the thing with
go charting is you know the guys that
are behind go charting the whole team
there they uh they're all in on order
flow right I mean I've had conversations
with them and you know they're they're
not just building a platform for Traders
um just to have one out there they
follow order flow as well so they get it
they understand its importance but
getting back to your question you know
when you scroll sometimes right
um you know you you can miss things what
I would suggest is you go to let me just
pull this chart up here and go you know
at the bottom of your screen down here
okay you have sort of different chart
layouts right this is full screen you
can go you know two rows like this you
can go side by side you can even go four
rows Okay so you know what I would
suggest is I would either use the sort
of the two columns or you know the the
four charts like this and you know keep
your chart you could even go like that
you know
um you know sort of keep your main chart
in Focus right
this is like your footprint that you're
going to be scrolling through you know
and just checking out things and just
get back here right they've got this
little arrow here that will point but
you could also keep a chart you don't if
you have a chart like this you know on
the right hand side or if you have it on
the left a bar chart you don't
necessarily need to have the bar
statistics on there just going to take
up space but you could scrunch up your
chart right the nice thing about the go
charting platform is you can scrunch up
your chart and you can still have the
indicators you know highlighting stuff
so like here this is your bullish
Prominent Point of control down here
43 72 and three quarters you can see
another one came in here to catch that
big move up right and you can see over
here earlier in the day when we got up
to uh you know that high up there at 08
there was a bearish prime reported
control another bearish Prominent Point
of control as the market sold down now
you don't need to necessarily if you're
concerned with you know sort of missing
some of these signals just keep a chart
you know use maximize your chart space
okay I said go charting I have where you
can split it up
um you know because it's one thing to be
looking at the footprint right and I get
it right you want to sort of scroll back
and and see things and the thing with uh
go charting depending on how you have
your
order flow settings right for the tick
manager right if you have auto mode you
can see I have it turned off auto mode
and
um if you turn it on you even get the
format volume where you can format uh
you sort of the the lot size Etc
I know some people like to go in and
sort of have this custom setting and
sometimes you know when they scroll you
know they sort of bunch up their chart
it will automatically aggregate their
chart I prefer to look at each tick by
itself
especially on the e-min he's really the
only chart that I would aggregate ticks
on is NQ or mnq just because you know if
you're trying to look at mnq for example
let's pull it up here
right and see now it's changing
obviously this other chart here
um it's you know it's quite the bars are
quite big Okay so
depending on your screen size I mean I
got big monitors so
you know I'm able to fit a lot of
information but you know if you're
trading if you're on a laptop or
something it could be very difficult
but you know what I would suggest is
definitely you know try to maximize
you'll find a good layout
for your
screen I mean you know you can make this
bar chart a little bit smaller right it
doesn't have to be so big but really
what you just want to be alerted to is
when those Prominent Point of controls
are coming in you know because you know
uh this are
sorry I can butcher in your name the
sarin nadaf
um you know because you're working on
building a a system you know around
Prominent Point of controls with uh
Divergence so you know definitely you
maximize your screen space
you know by splitting the screen up
that way it's just easier for you right
you always have one there that you can
watch right then you've got your other
chart that you can scroll back and forth
with right I mean on this other chart
you don't necessarily need to have the
footprint on there but it's good to have
it there you know so you know that's
sort of my tip to you if you're looking
for a way to
you know sort of keep track on what's
happening right now while you're looking
at other stuff um you know that may have
just happened
um and trying to figure you know which
trades to take so anyway guys I hope you
guys enjoy this quick video it's a short
one so I'll see you guys on the next
video bye-bye